Based on December's trailers alone, 2019 is
already shaping up to be a great year for
new movies.
Avengers: Endgame, Captain Marvel, and Godzilla:
King of the Monsters all saw new trailers,
and that's just the beginning.
"Let's do this"
Nobody would ever call 2012's Iron Sky a classic.
It barely even fits the criteria for a cult
classic.
And yet here we are with a sequel — and
not just any sequel, but a sequel funded with
$650,000 of fans' money through an Indiegogo
campaign.
Did anyone need it?
Nope.
Did anyone want it?
Well...based on the trailer, yeah.
Maybe we did want it, even if we never realized
it.
The first Iron Sky, for those who never felt
like watching it, was about Nazis from the
moon who invaded Earth.
Iron Sky The Coming Race pumps the gas on
the insanity, and in its own bizarre way,
it's beautiful.
The trailer showcases such visual treats as
Nazis riding on dinosaurs, spaceships, people
kicking Nazis riding on dinosaurs, and lizard
Hitler.
Or maybe that's dinosaur Hitler.
Who can tell?
“Seig  , mother f------.”
Look for it on January 16.
Aside from some leaked set photos, a trailer
released in September offered the first look
at Captain Marvel in all her superpowered,
granny-punching glory.
It revealed that the film would be set in
the '90s and would focus on a Carol Danvers
wiith amnesia who teams up with a young Nick
Fury with depth perception to fight the shapeshifting
Skrulls.
The second trailer, released in December,
builds on that premise with even more Kree
on Skrull action and a whirlwind montage of
Danvers flying things and reading files about
her past.
"I think I had a life here."
Action!
Intrigue!
Backstory!
Experience it all when Captain Marvel flies
into theaters on March 8.
It's been two years and change since Jordan
Peele's surprise smash hit Get Out hit theaters,
and fans have been clamoring for a follow-up
film ever since.
Well, the first trailer for Peele's sophomore
effort is here, and it's even more promising
than we'd hoped.
The trailer for Us cranks up the terror almost
immediately, briefly introducing us to a family
on vacation before tossing them into a...well,
into a horror movie.
First, their son runs off and meets a creepy
bleeding man on the beach.
Then, a group of masked strangers show up
at their house in the middle of the night
and reveal themselves to be the family's evil
doppelgangers.
If the trailer's any indication, Us is shaping
up to be one of the scariest movies of the
year.
Take a look on March 15.
December gave fans the first glimpse of what's
to come for Earth's Mightiest Heroes.
Well, what's left of them, anyway.
As we expected, everybody's really sad in
the first trailer for Endgame.
Half of the universe is gone, Iron Man's dying,
Captain America's crying, and Hawkeye's so
grief-stricken he's stabbing people in the
rain.
The world is screwed...and yet, there's hope!
Ant-Man's back, for one.
Even better, Captain Steve has a plan, which
can only mean good things.
"This is gonna work Steve …”
“I know it is."
The game ends on April 26.
A horror-themed spin on Superman's origin
story doesn't immediately smack of box office
success, but bear with us here.
Brightburn is being executive produced by
James Gunn, who's no stranger to both indie
horror and crowd-pleasing adventures.
Brightburn's trailer is fully aware of its
Smallville inspirations, which only makes
its dark turn into horror all the more satisfying.
The story sees a baby crash-landing on Earth
and being adopted by a husband and wife who
live on a farm.
As the boy grows, he begins to manifest creepy,
otherworldly powers — like Superman if he'd
been just a little more related to Satan.
Take a look when Brightburn lands in theaters
on May 27.
Amidst all the superheroes and nunnery in
today's cinematic universes, the biggest one
of them all has somehow snuck in on quiet
feet: Godzilla.
Starting with the 2014 film, Warner Bros.
has been building a connected cinematic monster
world that's all going to come together with
Godzilla: King of the Monsters.
The latest trailer reveals an epic film that
sees the big daddy lizard beast going head-to-head
with a bunch of kaiju while the fate of humanity
rests in the balance.
Mothra, Rodan, and King Ghidorah all get some
facetime in the latest trailer, promising
a city-sized smackdown that will change everything.
Well, at least until the next Godzilla movie.
In the meantime, here's hoping Ghidorah gets
a shot at Godzilla's Godzisticles.
Like the good old days.
Godzilla: King of the Monsters smashes into
a theater near you on May 31.
Chris Hemsworth, Liam Neeson, and Tessa Thompson
are all box office gold.
They've each starred in blockbuster franchises
and proved their worth in critically acclaimed
movies, and none of them are too shabby to
look at for two hours.
Still, we'd be remiss if we didn't mention
our reservations about Men in Black: International.
The Men in Black franchise has a tendency
to be hit or miss.
The first one was a '90s Will Smith treasure,
the second one was a shameless cash-in on
the first, and the third one breathed a little
life back into the whole shebang.
We really want Men in Black: International
to blow us away, and we'll get the chance
to find out if it does on June 14.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.